der trainer über die paar themen über
die man überhaupt noch lachen kann in
diesen ausgesprochen kranken zeiten ja
liebe zuschauer wieder mal liegt eine
sehr denkwürdige rexit woche hinter uns
endlose hängepartie ganz europa fragt
sich inzwischen wann kommen sie endlich
zu potte diese hänge briten
es kann doch nicht wahr sein drei tage
braucht das britische unterhaus müssen
darüber dass bild hinwegkommen
drei tage braucht das britische
unterhaus um nochmal festzustellen dass
sie theresa may stil mit der eu nicht
wollen aber keinen deal wollen sie auch
nicht sagt doch endlich mal was ihr
wollt erst mal ehrlich wie lange soll
sich dieser komische abschied dann noch
hinziehen
vielleicht verlassen wir die eu dann
über monate hin noch nicht oder wir
haben nicht mehr den schutz oder wir
treten vielleicht nie aus jetzt wird
heraus tritt also wohl verschoben aber
für was für was und wie viele
niederlagen musste may noch passieren
bevor sie mal zurück tritt nach all den
demütigungen das geht ja fast schon in
den sadomaso bereich meine damen und
herren wirklich ja nächsten dienstag
diskutieren zum dritten mal dieselben
englische politiker mit denselben
argumenten denselben deal dass kein
parlament das ist eine demenz klinik
wenn sie mich fragen ehrlich jetzt meine
was soll man zu den leuten wie boris
johnson überhaupt noch sagen we can't
wait to make you win win situation out
of this message warum können wir aus
diesem ganzen elend nicht eine win win
situation machen habe ich sage lieber
boris halva ja
roth geht ja nicht geht ja nicht und
selbst mit einem zweiten referendum
dinge ja alles nur von vorne los was
wenn wieder die doofen gewinnen ja
meistens gewinnen die doofen die sind
fast überall in überzahl wirklich dieser
engländer kommen wir inzwischen vor wir
sind partygast leute ich bin dann mal
weg der sich schon vor einer stunde
verabschiedet hat und einfach nicht
kraft dass wirklich alle wohl dass er
endlich abhaut alte regel nichts ist
nerviger als leute die einfach kein
gefühl dafür wann endlich schluss ist in
jedem fall im binnenmarkt bleiben aber
natürlich ohne im binnenmarkt zu bleiben
ja klar es steht eine menge auf dem
spiel
1,2 billionen dollar haben allein banken
und hedgefonds jetzt schon von der insel
runter geholt dabei ist noch gar nicht
drexhage ich glaube viele engländer
haben die konsequenzen gar nicht kapiert
andere versuchen wenigstens zu helfen
sie fahren zurzeit sonderschichten beim
süßwarenhersteller katjes am niederrhein
und schicken so viel lakritze und
fruchtgummi nach großbritannien ging
der grund sie rechnen mit dem
schlimmsten
[Musik]
das möchte mir gar nicht ausmalen wenn
die komplette fred ferkel versorgung
großbritanniens zusammenbricht weil da
mutter und man darf ja nie vergessen wer
die ganze lief kampagne also den kampf
für fish n chips finanziert hat
britische milliardäre waren das die aus
england nach dem break sind eine
steueroase machen wollen darum geht's
nicht um patriotismus leute die james
radcliffe der reichste mann englands
lieben ihr land aber nicht so sehr dass
sie selber da bleiben würden der
prominente braig sind befürworter
verlegt seinen wohnsitz nach monaco
seinem angeblich so geliebten vaterland
könnten so bis zu vier milliarden pfund
an steuern entgehen denn james dyson
gilt eigentlich als befürworter des brh
exit mit dem umzug nach singapur wollte
sich teyssen auf die wachsenden
asiatischen märkte konzentrieren ja
genau das glaube ich sofort wieder schön
den stöpsel aus der insel ziehen und
sich dann selber verpissen wir reden
hier natürlich auch über wahnvorstellung
das ist fakt viele brachse befürworter
wollen der backstop lösung für irland
nicht zustimmen weil sie angst haben
dass die böse eu sie dann für immer im
binnenmarkt hält das will überhaupt
keiner hier ja viele grüße aus
ja oder liebe briten wie man auf
ostdeutsch sagen würde
ein bisschen habe
wir gehen ganz europa in geiselhaft so
und für alle die inzwischen echt
probleme haben unsere an sich geliebten
mallorca nachbarn noch zu verstehen hier
der passende nachhilfeunterricht
english for work city mit liebesdiensten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo mein name ist tina enz bei visit
ist oliver kivanc to understand braig
sit ja genau weil kein mensch versteht
mir diese engländer oliver englisch sehr
britisch stand von kadir patient so
don't want note lassen wollen
accident ass well it's not present time
this is what we call sind dreifache
verneinung yes we say in german sind
britisch have one fc basel einen an der
waffel okay tina i have just one
question
und das sieht man ja nobody knows that
the british akku meetings sei tänze bei
question is who can save europe online
schotte halt so wurden putsch in frose
bettkante
tiefrot in letter to angela merkel des
fresh ideas for europe hat angela diesen
freitag ist etwa compter letter from the
strange klinik moment vom saarland china
bot ist saarland will oliver see
saarland ist es familien bundesland
smaller sind bielefeld seppel aufs
saarland akkord see salafisten moment
set to go fresh ideas
sie hätte credit hass auf die cdu
vorsitzende hat angeregt mit frankreich
zusammen einen gemeinsamen europäischen
flugzeugträger zu bauen
die bild flugzeugträger ein love me
schlappe wie can't even repair bloody
said on this is our last lessons for
today kids peter paul and mary dreien to
krax it but i can't be called to fucking
stupid what now know we are going to the
pub und trinkt ouattara mal englisch
bier an tobias ott rang wie frau get
your city ein und alexis tipps
kommunalwahl let's get drunk prostata
den ausbau für weitere videos klickt
unten und abonniert auch unseren channel
alles im kasten
ok
[Musik]
wo geht's hier raus
scheiße